[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue ce soir
la question c'est au tour d'emmanuel
macro et du déconfinement le président
de la république at il réussi son pari
c'est la deuxième étape en tout cas du
déconfinement à partir de 2 bat et on en
débat comme chaque mardi avec alexis
brézet bonsoir alexis on soit vincent
directeur des rédactions du figaro
faut-il le rappeler est avec nous ce
soir avec vous pascal perrineau bonsoir
pascal merci bonsoir nous on rappelle
les faut-il encore là aussi le rappelez
vous êtes professeur à sciences po et
que votre dernier ouvrage en date on le
voit il est à lire bien entendu c'est le
populisme aux presses universitaires de
france
on reviendra aussi ce soir sur l'autre
événement à venir la manifestation des
policiers demain à 13h devant
l'assemblée nationale
approuvez-vous la présence de gérald
darmanin aux côtés des policiers lors de
leurs manifestations
c'est la question qu'on pose depuis la
fin de la matinée sur le site du figaro
et ses débats qu'on aura en deuxième
partie
mais d'abord une question vous j'ai deux
réponses
enfin on a moins bien avoir votre avoue
vie irez-vous prendre un café demain en
terrasse un mois que ce soit plutôt un
petit tour au cinéma on sera mercredi
finalement en attendant une question
emmanuel macron réussite il son pari
c'est la question qu'on pose sur twitter
alors il ya encore des sceptiques des
inquiet d'abord vous puisque vous
répondez pour l'instant majoritairement
non il y a également des sceptiques ou
des inquiet comme la réalisatrice lilas
bouadma qui est membre du conseil
scientifique
alors vous savez que le conseil
scientifique s'est saisi de cette
question et a émis un avis en fin de la
semaine dernière sur notre inquiétude je
pense dans cet avis est perceptible sur
ce qui va se passer parce que la
temporalité le fait que ces réouvertures
ne soit pas lié à des critères
sanitaires strictes nous rend inquiet
al'inverse voici les arguments et la
réponse en quelque sorte du porte parole
du gouvernement ce matin gabriel attal
qu'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui que les
signaux sont au vert
et ça démontre que le président de la
république a eu raison dans ce
calendrier
évidemment qu'il faut pas baisser la
garde évidemment qu'il faut rester
vigilant vous l'avez dit il ya des
variants il ya toujours des risques mais
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place un
calendrier de réouverture qui est très
progressif qui est prudent qui se fait
par étapes et moi j'ai confiance dans la
responsabilité des français
y est vous êtes sceptiques ou vous êtes
confiant les indicateurs quand même
plaide en faveur du déconfinement pour
l'instant au deuxième apportant
perramant je suis donc confiant tout cas
optimiste en tout cas je pense que cette
affaire a suffisamment duré pour essayer
de savourer un petit peu dotées liste
quand on a des raisons d'en avoir et là
dans les chiffres il ya vraiment des
raisons de vent d'optimisme en france et
d'ailleurs dans toute l'europe
si on regarde les courbes en gros elles
sont toutes les mêmes alors il ya le
portugal et au royaume uni qui sont
beaucoup plus bas que tout le monde
le royaume uni parce qu'ils ont fasciné
tout le monde va tout le monde la moitié
de la population a compté tout le monde
et le portugal pour d'autres raisons
puis après le gros du peloton européen
tourne ou même à peu près au même niveau
saab est chez tout le monde à peu près
en même temps ce qui d'ailleurs permet
de relativiser l'importance des
politiques que peuvent avoir les uns ou
les autres
si ça se trouve tout ça où il ya des
facteurs qui sont des facteurs de
dynamique ça monte puis après sa baisse
et puis peut-être sud et les facteurs
liés au climat ajoute là dessus le la
question du vaccin et on arrive à peu
près partout une vraie décrue forte des
niveaux qui sont aujourd'hui pas
préoccupant donc évidemment qu'il faut
ré ouvrir et bon j'entends la dame là
dessus du conseil du conseil
scientifique mais bon qu'est ce que j'ai
moi je me souviens de ce qu'on nous
avait raconté en janvier vous avez dit
quand on est mieux me qu'on avait pas
voulu profiter tout fuit et on me dit
c'est trop horrible ça va être hors de
contrôle ça va être exponentielle non
sap éditeur de contrôle ça peut être
exponentielle
c'est vrai que en février mars la courbe
française a crû un peu plus haut que ça
tombe de pays européens mais après c'est
une question de s qu'il fallait mieux ça
ou est ce que il valait mieux arrêter à
nouveau toute la population mettre les
enfants des fins fermer les écoles etc
moi je pense que grosso modo la démo de
l'addition était plus été bonne et je me
suis en avril quand il a décidé de re
confiné à minima ce qu'on nous a dit
karine lacombe gilbert de ré rémy
salomon antoine flahault de là tout le
parti des cons finis c'est une
catastrophe
il n'en fait pas assez c'est trop tard
il fallait faire plus tôt c'est trop peu
il faut tout faire mais c'est trop court
il faut que ça dure jusqu'au val était
bon il ay paris les a pas écoutés ils
représentent pas les écouter et puis si
jamais ils avaient raison ce
qu'évidemment je n'espère près ce que je
ne crois pas il sera toujours temps de
refermer une fois de plus mais
franchement ça n'en prend pas le chemin
oui moi je partage en effet ce sentiment
au fond
à quoi assiste-t-on parce que sur un an
on a eu à la fois une gestion où le
politique était étroitement soumis aux
sanitaires et en particulier au conseil
scientifique
ça n'a pas été une franche réussite là
on a l'impression que depuis le début de
l'année il ya une émancipation du
pouvoir politique et que le pouvoir
politique reprend un peu la main et
d'une certaine manière on a jusqu'à
maintenant on n'a qu'à se féliciter
parce qu'au fond la gestion par le
politique a été meilleur peut-être que
par la gestion pure du sanitaire à
partir du moment où le politique intègre
les indicateurs sanitaires à toute la
panoplie des indicateurs sanitaires et
là quand on les regarde sur les
réanimations sur le nombre de morts par
jour sur les hospitalisations sur le
nombre bien sûr le nombre de morts sur
le taux de contamination
tous les indicateurs vont dans le sens
de l' orange au vert et ça c'est nouveau
vous avez maintenant un rythme de
vaccination qui on a dépassé les 20
millions venant d'un million de
projection de premières injections ont
il semble que maintenant il y a les
stocks pour augmenter assez rapidement
jusqu'au 30 millions donc là on va
participer à une immunisation d'une
partie importante de la population par
le même que les 18 ans et plus puissent
avoir accès à brève échéance à la
vaccination
donc jusqu'à maintenant ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'y aura pas éventuellement
parce que quand on regarde tous les taux
gens regardez ça avant de venir vous
apercevez qu'on est en surtout ses taux
que je dont je parlais tout à l'heure à
peu près au niveau de septembre 2
septembre dernier
ça n'a pas empêché qu'après septembre
mais attention c'est l'été il ya les
paris sont donc là vous avez deux
variables qui nous font peut-être
envisager c'est de l'analyse l'espoir
bien sûr ce sont les deux qui nous font
peut-être envisager une sortie du tunnel
et ce qui est intéressant aussi
l'opinion le ressens comme tel je
regardais la dernière enquête
up sur le perçu par l'opinion de la
lutte contre la copie et les indicateurs
sont pour la première fois des
indicateurs positifs depuis très
longtemps par exemple c'est une majorité
absolue qui considèrent maintenant que
ils font confiance au gouvernement sur
le terrain social et économique
sur le terrain des vaccinations 52% des
français est presque un français sur
deux sur la sortie du confinement
donc en termes nous voyait deux
structures d'opinion là aussi les choses
bougent les français ressentent
différemment la stratégie de lutte
contre la copie de 19
il ya une autre il ya c'est intéressant
que vous soulignez ces indicateurs
il ya des indicateurs qui sont révélés
ce matin dans le figaro dans une analyse
de jean pierre robin et qui sont ici du
cevipof et qui montrent que les français
sont sont justement sur la gestion du
confinement des champions de la colère
de la peur et qui supporte mois le
confinement que les britanniques les
allemands et j'ai envie de vous poser la
question inverse est ce que les mesures
demain qui entre en vigueur de
déconfinement au regard de ces
indicateurs la vo suffire vont suffire
pour le satisfaire le besoin de liberté
et je non non ils vont pas suffire c'est
pour ça qu'il ya les étapes suivantes
qui vont arriver le 9 juin le couvre-feu
va passer à 23 heures moi je pense qu'on
pourrait notamment d'anticiper certaines
qui est de dire arrêtons de porter le
masque en extérieur tout le monde sait
ça ne sert à rien tout le monde sait
qu'il ya zéro contamination à
l'extérieur à l'extérieur pas du
domicile parce que dans les statistiques
on mélange candé l'extérieur mais dedans
les gens qui sont l'excellence de leur
domicile qui fait dans des bureaux dans
des commerçants à l'extérieur dehors
sous le ciel est donc dire qu aux gens
et notamment la avec l'arrivée des beaux
jours qu'il faut qu'au bord de l'eau sur
les plages dans les parcs porter des
masques ça n'a aucun sens ça les énerve
ça les énerve plus qu'autre chose ça ne
sert à rien ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'on pourrait accepter c'est vrai
que c'est un peu paradoxal de voir
aujourd'hui monsieur vers ans dont on se
souvient parce que là on est en train
d'expliquer que les politiques et des
groupes ont pris les bonnes décisions
mais si les français sur les nerfs mais
c'est aussi qu'ils en ont pris
énormément de mauvaises et donc on se
souvient quand même de l'époque où tous
ces gens là nous expliquer qu'il fallait
pas porter de masque alors
qu'aujourd'hui qu'on se dit bonbons à
l'excellent on n'a plus besoin disent
non mais vous allez garder c'est pas
tout de suite attendait un peu attendre
d'être absolument sûr peut-être qu'à la
fin du mois d'août ça ira mieux
des gens peuvent plus donc c'est pour ça
que quand on parle du confinement et
sebastian espèce de deux divergences
entre la reprise en main très très juste
de parler pascal sur la question du
confinement et dont on peut dire c'est
une bonne chose mais le problème c'est
que en face de ça il aurait fallu il
faudrait que les mesures sanitaires et
étaient les bonnes ou soit encore les
bonnes et c'est vrai que quand on
regarde on en a parlé un milliard de
fois mais enfin les masques si tu que
c'est une catastrophe
les tests et d'une catastrophe les lits
de réanimation c'est un désastre et la
vaccination dont on dit qu'elle augmente
chaque fois moi je regarde les chiffres
on est quand même dans le peloton des
très très très bas enfin bon alors c'est
vrai qu'on bien sûr que ça augmente tous
les jours heureusement en fin d'année
derrière l'estonie la pologne de lui
vous êtes à la deuxième page savez c'est
ça il ya non mais il ya quarante pays
devant nous donc y compris en europe
l'espagne est devant nous l'italie fait
mieux le pays bas fait mieux le
luxembourg fait mieux donc
et je vous parle pas de la pologne
l'estonie donc comment dire évidemment
ça progresse évidemment ça joue
et à la fin des fins on peut espérer
bâtir l'unité mais il faut pas non plus
expliquer qu'on a tout fait bien et que
tout est formidable non on peut pas dire
peut-on parler de déconfinement alors
même que le couvre feu subsiste ça a été
un peu seul c'est en effet la re
découverte d'une liberté partiel 1
voilà et on en a encore certainement
pour plusieurs mois de cette liberté
partiel et bien sûr il y aura nécessité
dans les espaces clos de continuer à
être prudent avec le masque avec les
gestes barrière ça je crois que oui il
faut faire il faut faire attention ça
n'est pas du jour au lendemain qu'on
passera un déconfinement toi pas
normalement le fin juin enfin je vois
pas ce qui est prévu et on peut espérer
qu'on ne s'y tiendra il y aura plus de
confinement il y aurait plus de
limitation des déplacements il y aura
plus de couvre-feu y aura plutôt ces
choses là
espérons cela de l'année dernière c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé et il n'y
avait pas les pas que ça c'est ce que
nous dit babineau internet internautes
récurrents fidèles de figaro live il y a
une dynamique naturelle du virus
on pourrait observer la même des crues
l'année dernière le virus est le maître
des horloges notre t-il avec un brin un
brin d'ironie il ya quand même des alors
des indicateurs qui al'inverse eux je
sais pas si cela plaide en faveur du des
confirmands mais qui reste un peu
alarmant c'est par exemple la saturation
encore en ile-de-france des capacités de
des capacités de réanimation pas vrai
quand on vous demande et d'insouciance
il ya de la place
simplement c'est une façon de construire
la statistique où on part d'un nombre de
lits qui était le nombre de l'icann au
début de la crise sur lequel on applique
des coefficients va m'aimer en fait tout
ça c'est une puisque quand on poursuit
les courbes on arrive de temps en temps
à des à des services qui sont remplis à
120% ça n'existe pas donc cette
déconstruction statistiques il reste
encore beaucoup de monde en réanimation
mais ya pas de saturation des animations
il n'y a pas un médecin qui vous dirai
ça aujourd'hui et les médecins qui sont
dans leur cabinet ou disent tous on n'a
plus un cas à comme vous êtes tribu est
justement ce genre de construction 16 et
statistiques
c'est pour faire pour faire augmenter
les capacités devraient ou non contraire
non c'est d'ailleurs un mystère
bureaucratique et administratif je pense
que c'est un mélange d'apport de il ya
une volonté de notamment nomination de
l'ap-hp de dire on n'a pas fait
d'erreurs donc on n'avait pas besoin de
plus et c est donc il faut convaincre
les français que refaire reporter sur
les forêts dont pour faire reporter sur
une forme fait peur en disant les les
réanimations saturé et quand on leur dit
ah ben si les rennais sont saturés faut
faire plus joli
ah ben non il est pas besoin de plus de
lits en fait ça va très bien si si si
mais s'ils avaient plus de lits il y
aurait plus il y aurait plus de malades
et donc y aurait plus de morts et donc
on relâcherait les efforts donc c'est un
espèce de raisonnement qui se mord la
queue pour toujours aboutir à faire
peser la contrainte sur les sens les
gens les citoyens aient jamais sur la
structure administrative et
bureaucratique je parle pas des
soignants je porte de la structure
administrative et bureaucratique qui
essaient de toujours prouver qu'elle n'a
jamais eu tort vous passez votre temps à
oui on est
france si vous voulez l'état j'avais
tort c'est un principe de base est la
puissance publique c'est vrai on a une
culture
à cet égard à extrêmement différente de
ce qui se passe chez beaucoup de nos
voisins européens où la puissance
publique en effet n'a jamais tort et au
contraire désigne les usagers comme
étant de potentiels délinquants
il ya les réactions des internautes sont
assez assez divergentes enfin son s'est
polarisée alors d'un côté il y a
effectivement c'est cet internaute qui
me disait peut-on parler de
déconfinement leur même que le couvre
feu subsiste chardon bleu est plutôt
attentiste il faut peut-être attendre
quelques semaines encore avant de
pouvoir affirmer qu emmanuel macron a
réussi son pari
jean pierre qui nous dit pour moi c'est
plus sain déconfinement politique qu'un
déconfinement sanitaires et gisèle new
deal déconfinement ne fait qu on
commençait malheureusement les français
vont se relâcher
comme pour les précédents nous n'avons
pas atteint l'immunité collectif et
sommes très vulnérables un quatrième
confinement septembre nous pend au nez
ça c'est vous avez un peu le panorama
des deux réactions de type de réaction
que en a et puis bon il ya le cam dateam
macron qui réagir du disant de toute
façon quel que soit le sondage sur
macron le nom l'emportera toujours et
olemps prédit que macro on va réussir si
les gens appliquent les consignes cet
été la question que vous vous posez sur
twitter c'était emmanuel macron va-t-il
réussir son pari bien sûr c'est un c'est
un pronostic quand vous demandez mais
pour l'instant vous êtes plutôt
sceptique puisque vous répondez non à
59%
si je pense qu'effectivement mettre le
monde le nom de macron de danse
habilleuse les réponses et par ailleurs
pardon c'est un tout petit peu je sais
pas du tout une critique de personnes
qui font les questions que c'est un tout
petit peu puéril de diass que de mac ont
réussi c'est pas un pari de mâcon
question c'est est-ce que les décisions
de déconfinement sont bonnes ou pas
bonne c'est comme ça dans toute l'europe
et dire enfin il ya un côté un peu jeux
de cour de récréation on dit est ce que
il a réussi il a raté c'est fait c'est
pas ça la question
d'accord mais est-ce que si justement le
déconfinement réussi est ce que s'il ya
une adhésion de la population est ce que
justement l'exécutif en particulier
emmanuel macron son entourage n'a pas
tendance à s'attribuer on va bien sûr
qui cela tout ira mais c'est pas une
raison parce qu'ils savent mais oui
s'attribuera et si ça va mal ses
adversaires lui attribueront le fait que
ça va mal mais après c'est un lave la
vie c'est un tout petit peu plus
complexe que ça donc c'est pas une
raison pour tomber dans ce panneau là
après la question c'est est ce que
l'opinion
si les choses s'arrangent pas ce
qu'elles finissent quand même un priori
ils finiront pas s'arranger
est-ce que les gens oublieront ce qui
n'a pas marché indien allez ça va mieux
on commence un nouvel r ça va être le
pari du gouvernement légitime d'ailleurs
de dire allez on part sur des bases
nouvelles et on va faire des pleins de
choses ensemble
ou bien est-ce que les gens diront oui
bon d'accord là ça va mieux mais où on
vous en veux toujours de ce que vous
avez raté
et ça franchement je n'en sais rien et
je sais pas je pense que personne ne
peut savoir est votre point de vue
justement evans au regard de votre
expérience et de regarder des
indicateurs justement concon site
s'ils voulaient il y a en ce moment un
voile c'est le voile de cette affaire
sanitaire mais le voile cache de plus en
plus mal les autres problèmes qui
restent extrêmement vif sur le terrain
économique et social et sur le terrain
de la sécurité ou plutôt de l'insécurité
et ça fera le lien avec le thème suivant
mes racines locales
je regardais en venant les enquêtes en
particulier région par région qui sont
faites et ça me frappe de voir que même
dans des régions relativement paisible
qui n'ont pas connu d'enjeux
d'insécurité vous avez la sécurité qui
intervient même parfois comme enjeu
devant le sanitaire aujourd'hui ici et
maintenant
par exemple dans la région voyez centre
val de loire j'ai pas une région vous
voyez qui a connu de véritables affaires
de traumatisante sur le terrain de la
sécurité
eh bien c'est la sécurité qui est
considéré par les électeurs comme le
principal enjeu devant le légèrement
devant le sanitaire pour les prochaines
régionales
elle veut comme vous l'avez dit ça fait
nécessaire pour la deuxième partie alors
fabien roussel yannick jadot jordan
bardella olivier faur vous me demandez
quel est leur point commun bon ils font
pas partie des républicains bonne
réponse mais ils seront également
présents à la manifestation des
policiers demain devant l'assemblée
nationale et avec que le ministre de
l'intérieur
approuvez-vous alors la présence de
gérald darmanin aux côtés des policiers
lors de leurs manifestations
pour l'instant vous êtes plutôt négatif
sur le fond vous répondez plus tôt par
non sur le site du figaro 54% un peu
plus de 54% avant le début de l'émission
la 55,18 au moment où on se parle avant
d'en débattre
d'abord je vous propose d'écouter
l'intéressé voici comment il justifie sa
présence demain après midi
il s'est exprimé tout à l'heure devant
l'assemblée nationale la police
républicaine la gendarmerie nationale
son à travers les différents
gouvernements à travers différents
majorité les vigies de la sécurité
publique les protecteurs des libertés
fondamentales et finalement les premiers
acteurs sociaux d'un territoire je crois
que il est important en effet de
soutenir la police et si je peux me
permettre il faut le soutenir tout le
temps et à tout moment
alors avant de vous faire réagir je vous
propose d'écouter deux points de vue
divergents d'abord celui de stanislas
guéri dit le patron de la république en
marche va pas manifestés pour contre
lui-même
évidemment il sera dans son rôle de
ministre de l'intérieur c'est-à-dire
deux premiers policiers de france
il ira saluer les policiers dans un
moment je pense qu'il est essentiel que
la nation toute entière montre à quel
point nous sommes derrière nos forces de
l'ordre et la vie opposés et à l'opposé
la vie de françois xavier bellamy ce
matin sur europe 1
c'est très étonnant c'est la première
fois je crois qu'on voit un ministre de
l'intérieur manifester contre sa propre
inaction je sais pas moi je crois que
quand on est ministre de l'intérieur on
a mieux à faire que manifester on a les
leviers pour agir et c'est ça qui est
attendu aujourd'hui de sherman pascal à
ma connaissance cette présence d'un
ministre de l'intérieur une
manifestation c'est une première
ah oui pour un ministre l'intérieur
c'est une première en revanche il ya des
ministres qui ont déjà participé à des
manifestations
c'était le cas par exemple de gabriella
talent non pas quand il était sur des
enjeux je crois du magnifique des
mathématiques d'écologie donc voila mais
c'est vrai que la participation à ce
niveau de responsabilité
da ministre de l'intérieur et à c'est
assez étonnante parce qu'il ya un côté
juge et partie il ya un côté au fond
d'un homme qui va se déplacer demain
pour participer ou salué une
manifestation afin de se prévenir lui
même de l'urgence des problèmes
vous voyez donc il ya un côté un peu un
peu paradoxal est un peu un peu étonnant
parce que certes comme le disait le
ministre de l'intérieur l'opinion est
derrière sa police il suffit de regarder
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion je
regardais le dernier baromètre de
confiance du cevipof qui a quelques
semaines ses 69 % des français qui font
confiance à la police et donc demain on
verra si dans la rue aux côtés des
forces de l'ordre il y as nombreux
françaises et de nombreux français qui
viendront témoigner leur solidarité avec
des forces de l'ordre qui ont subi des
agressions terrible et répété dans l'est
dans les dernières semaines
donc voilà est ce que on a besoin en
plus de du soutien du ministre
l'intérieur mystère de la mise de
l'intérieur et le chef de la police
c'est le premier policier de france
bon voilà il a une fonction hiérarchique
par rapport à cette police et il ne faut
pas qu'il oublie cette fonction
hiérarchique et il faut pas mélanger les
genres je crois hélas il ya un léger
mélange des genres le jeu mélange des
genres alexis parmi les commentaires
d'internautes qui répondent à la
question qui posait sur le site du
figaro les deux points de vue différents
il est d'abord celui d'un nom qui nous
dit c'est pas son rôle et à la verse une
maxime qui dit un patron doit être
toujours avec ses troupes quand il ya
des graves problèmes
je pense qu'il ya un côté un peu
colossal finesse dans cette affaire
c'est un coup d'astuces c'est assez
malin en vérité parce que imaginons-le
inverse imaginons que demain n'y aille
pas et que demain il ya une
manifestation avec les policiers
l'ensemble des responsables des partis
politiques sauf ou mélenchon les
insoumis pour des raisons sur lequel on
reviendra peut-être on qu'on dise tout
le monde était évidemment le monial mise
de l'intérieur depuis son bureau n'a
même pas daigné venir saluer c'est tout
bon il a il a un problème il s'est dit
fou pour les raisons que pascal 26-1
très bien le peu de la police et
populaire il vaut mieux être avec caen
face donc je suis leur chef donc je les
suis
yg rod je n'avais que je suis avec vous
et je partage vos vos revendications
c'est vrai que quand on est ministre un
tout petit peu bizarre parce que les
revendications
c'est à lui qu'elle s'adresse en partie
c'est on garde des sceaux qu'elle
s'adresse beaucoup parce qu'au fond ce
qu'ils réclament de plus en plus c'est
une
tour de vis pénale et ça c'est pas le
médiateur elle s'adresse de façon
globale au gouvernement est responsable
politique en disant nous sommes en
première ligne
nous en prenons plein la figure nous
payons un tribut effrayant aux activités
tous les jours refus d'obtempérer aux
incivilités aux agressions aux blessures
et fier et jusqu'au jusqu'au mort et et
vous passez votre temps à nous rendre
hommage à dire que nous sommes les
combattants que nous sommes que nous
sommes en guerre et en guerre en gare et
nous demandent les moyens et donc c'est
vrai que voir le ministre l'intérieur se
joindre aux rangers oui je suis avec
vous il ya un côté un peu un peu facile
un peu malin un peu politiciens dans
cette affaire bon mais après tout
maintenant c'est aussi aux policiers le
et à ses opposants de droite de gauche
de prendre au moins d'accord battu les
soutiens tu avec eux bon ben alors
maintenant ok est ce que tu es d'accord
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour faire
des peines planchers est ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour revoir leur donnant
sur l'arrière et sur les mineurs pour
que me monter la majorité pénale est ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour revoir le
régime d'exécution des peines
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
construire des prisons c'est ça les
réponses qu'on attend c'est pas
uniquement de deux d'aller manifester ou
de se planter devant l'assemblée en
disant je suis avec vous parce que je
suis votre chef
donc après tout très bien si 9,6 ici
vous soutenir ses troupes mais il faut
les soutenir jusqu'au bout pas que dans
la rue il faut les soutenir dans les
faits et donc je pense que le rôle de le
maintenant des oppositions c'est à dire
aller ok mais jusqu'au bout
alors justement en plus que vous en
parliez il ya une opposition qui
mais plutôt absente dans cette dans
cette mobilisation c'est la france
atomise enfin un truc à jean luc
mélenchon est est ce que c'est un bon
calcul de la part de la france non je ne
crois pas je ne crois pas parce qu'une
fois de plus mélenchon ne parle qu'à son
public et c'est ce que glisser un regard
de sa est ce que c'est ce que ça peut
consolider le nom seul coup ça l'aidera
certainement pas parce que vous avez
d'ailleurs une partie des électeurs de
la france insoumise qui est préoccupé
également par la montée de la petite la
moyenne délinquance et qui choqués en
plus de sa part les meurtres récents
ça n'est pas simplement ce ne sont pas
simplement les électeurs de droite qui
sont choqués par cela et d'ailleurs on
le voit dans une évolution tout à fait
intéressante quelle évolution du
candidat du parti communiste
monsieur fabien roussel qui tient un
discours maintenant très ferme sur
l'enjeu de la sécurité et qui lui a un
objectif alors certes il parle de très
bas mais il appartient un peu au même
milieu de la gauche de la gauche et qui
se dit voilà le gros problème s'il pc en
est là où il est aujourd'hui c'est à
dire 1 ou 2%
c'est parce que il a perdu le dialogue
avec les couches populaires et la
demande de sécurité qu'il ya dans ces
couches populaires
oui donc de les reconquérir comment vous
interprétez dans ce cas là que justement
un élu communiste comme le maire de
villejuif
aujourd'hui retire
retire les ldd les tasers et à sa police
mais parce que le parti communiste est
un parti tout petit aujourd'hui mais qui
est un parti qui est traversée par ce
qu'il traverse d'ailleurs toute la
gauche est ce que la gauche doit
reconquérir sur le terrain de la
sécurité un électorat populaire qu'elle
a laissé peu à peu partir pour faire
plaisir à quelques milieux de la
bourgeoisie bohème libéral libertaire ou
est ce qu'elle doit mener un combat qui
est un combat républicain dans lequel
elle la gauche d'antan n'oubliez pas que
le droit de sûreté est un droit de
l'homme
c'est un droit de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et là on a
l'impression qu'une partie de la gauche
jusqu'au coeur en effet du parti
communiste du parti socialiste de
génération point s de la france
insoumise a complètement oublié ce
message qui était le sien jadis il y à
il ya un an une partie d'eux c'est à
dire de cette gauche manifesté à
l'unisson de toute une butte de la
gauche et d'une partie de la gauche
international pour demander le
désarmement des polices à la suite delà
de la sphère de georges floyd aux
etats-unis est-ce qu'il ya une dérive
mais ça fait vingt ans que ça dure d'une
dérive de la gauche qui petit kit
essentiel de défendre le peuple défendre
les catégories populaires et qui tout
s'est petit à petit des habitués sans
doute parce qu'elle ne croyait plus à la
possibilité au fond de revoir le système
de remettre en cause le système
capitaliste qu'au fond la défense du
peuple ça peut passer par dire on va
remettre en cause ce système injuste
bon après des mois où la gauche qui
croient plus je cherche d'autres causes
et elle va trouver les droits des
minorités et il va se dire que
finalement sa nouvelle clientèle ce sont
ces minorités minorités ethniques
raciales
yt sexuelle minorité de tout de tout
ordre
ça a été quand même théorisé sais pas
c'est pas des comment dire c'est pas des
théoriciens de droite qui vont inventer
sa ou des politologues hors sol s'était
théorisé même par terra nova aux partis
se disent qu'avant a dit bon finalement
en gros toutes ces ouvriers ont ils sont
passés au front national on les laisse
tomber les catégories populaires on
laisse tomber les catégories moyennes
restent tomber on va s'occuper des
minorités et donc la gauche est en train
une partie sans rencontre donc certains
maires de terrain s'en rende compte
10000 faucon reconquiert sais c'est que
ces sujets sur la sécurité il faut qu'on
reconquiert la question de la maîtrise
de l'immigration
c'était évidemment un sujet qui
travaille en profondeur les catégories
populaires qui sont qui prennent les
conséquences de l'immigration contre les
deux plein fouet bien davantage que les
bourgeois qui vit tranquillement dans
leur quartier et donc il ya un ensemble
de deux mères qui se rend compte de ça
et et mélangeront bien qu'il est
tiraillé puisqu'il vient lui d'une
gauche plutôt républicaine d'une gauche
ouvriériste et sociale et il est
tiraillé entre cette gauche-là quissac
gauche originel et cette nouvelle gauche
et ses nouveaux amis à la fois d'ultra
gauche est toujours de la défense des
minorités y fait un coin il a fait un
meeting la ya deux jours où il essayait
de revenir au social les luttes sociales
les revendications cela est là il a des
revendications de policiers du je n'y
vais pas mais c'est quand même fort il
dit ça dépanne hommages se sont une
magnifique magnifique des revendications
corporatistes
mais c'est quoi ce n'est pas défendre
les revendications des gens c'est
absolument inouïe ou alors si c'est si
ce n'est de dire que les revendications
de la police sont convenables parce que
cette corporation qu'elle apprécie c'est
condamnable
voilà c'est ça le fond c'est à dire
qu'il ya un vrai problème
en gros la police instrument de l'état
bourgeois oppresseurs oppresseurs
autrefois des ouvriers des prolétaires
et oppresseur aujourd'hui des minorités
et
on a changé de prolétariat tout à fait
est au delà de ce qu alexis dit je crois
qu'il y à quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre la police pense mal elle pense
mal parce qu'en effet il ya de
nombreuses enquêtes qui sortent
aujourd'hui qui montre ce qui n'est pas
complètement nouveau que dans les
métiers de l'ordre en effet le front
national jadis est aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national en effet est
sur-représentée et quelque part dans
l'attitude que la france insoumise
adoptent il ya une espèce de sanction
vous pensez mal donc on n'ira pas vous
soutenir vous voyez tout comme mais
c'est là où c'est plus préoccupant pour
eux les ouvriers pense de plus en plus
mal parce que quand vous regardez en
effet le modèle voix de loi c'est le
rassemblement national
vous me faites penser justement à cette
interview d'un universitaire ou plus
exactement d'un juriste américain la
semaine dernière par the new cities qui
disait que le aujourd'hui le critère le
dernier critère seuls critères distincts
discriminant c'est devenu le diplôme et
donc la césure c'est si vous avez un
diplôme vous tous vous permettre si vous
n'avez pas de diplôme
vous ne pouvez rien vous permettre et
vous êtes exco mais là on touche du
doigt toutes les études
qui ont été faites par un peu par la
fondapol et qu'on a notamment relayé
dans le fion l'a décrite de la gauche
dans l'europe tout entière c'est à dire
que va t on la gauche abandonne peu ou
prou la défense de ce cd catégorie
qu'elle était censée représenter c'est à
dire les ouvriers des employés les
catégories modestes les gens que le
système droit et laisse de côté s'ils
abandonnent cela uniquement pour au fond
les minorités ethniques les mineurs
étaient raciale et de mes bébés les
reculs hercules et reclus et dans tous
les pays européens c'est la même chose
là encore c'est un peu comme l'épidémie
faut arrêter de regarder que notre
nombril si tous pareils ça des choses
pareilles pas dans toute l'europe ça
prouve qu'il ya une cause unique à tous
à qui celles-ci pas une autre et puis il
ya une gauche qui ne comprend pas si le
risque est en train de se passer dans
les sociétés il ya ce remarquable livre
de david goodheart vous allez qui
s'appelle la tête là la main et le coeur
et qui montrent que de plus en plus il a
une classe cognitives la classe des
diplômés de ceux qui sont censés savoir
et puis de plus en plus les métiers de
la main les métiers manuels et les
métiers du coeur ceux dont on a vu le
rôle est extrêmement important en pleine
crise de lakovic 19 il dit c'est
peut-être la fracture est essentielle de
nos sociétés cette opposition entre une
classe cognitives et les métiers de la
main et du coeur et si la gauche ne se
pose pas le problème de la réinsertion
parmi ces très nombreux individus hommes
et femmes qui ont des métiers de la main
et du coeur élira vers la
marginalisation à vers la
marginalisation absolue je rappelle que
le débat était consacrée à présence de
gérald darmanin on a un peu d'essais de
relevés météo ne veut pas rester
indéfiniment si gérald darmanin que
soient ses mérites
je pas mal de commentaires da tarde donc
gelé
de babineau qui lui disait un ministre
est censé apporter des solutions
la présence de darmanin et étrange est
inédite général escape si cela était
suivie d'actions concrètes on dirait
qu'il ne fait que soutenir ses troupes
mais face à sa politique on sait très
bien que darmanin via faire de la
communication cet autre internaute qui
nous dinars il n'a rien à y faire par
contre il faut qu'il donne des moyens à
la police de faire son job et gisèle
approuve la présence du ministre
intérieur demain en nous disant oui les
s'il est sincère et motivés pour changer
les choses
masi malheureusement si pleins de bonne
volonté qu'il soit il est obligé de
suivre les prérogatives de l'exécutif
qui n'ont fait qu'accentuer les
injustices ça ne pourra pas aller
approuvez-vous donc la présence de
gérald darmanin aux côtés des
manifestations de policiers lors de ma
et bien vous répondez non à 55 23 % mais
assez assez partagez vous pouvez
continuer à voter en tous les cas cette
manifestation elle sera cette
mobilisation sera à suivre demain en
direct sur figaro live avec bruno drye
en studio guillaume points et notre
équipe sur place et on commencera dès
8h30 pas pour vous faire vivre la
réouverture est là l'installation des
terrasses et on verra s'il ya la pluie
ou pas le fait pas ce sera de 8h30 à
9h30 et vous nous direz pas ce que vous
faites et vous poserai toutes vos
questions à elsa trop trop gillot qui
aura pas mal de réponse à vous donner
sur ce qu'on peut faire pas faire
comment s'y retrouver dans ce marc dos
santos maquis d'interdiction et
d'autorisation est là également notre
équipe sera sur place dans les rues de
paille merci beaucoup et on se retrouve
demain même heure même endroit au tour
de guillaume roquette merci pascal
mercier alexis
[Musique]